los aviones de guerra franceses ya no
pueden utilizar el espacio aéreo de
argelia aunque no se ha hecho ningún
anuncio oficial para ir recibí el
mensaje después de que rechazaran a dos
de sus aviones francia usaba la ruta
para enviar aeronaves desde y hacia la
región del sahel donde el 5000 de sus
efectivos ayudan a los aliados
regionales a luchar contra los
yihadistas este es el último movimiento
de la creciente tensión diplomática
entre francia y argelia que ha empeorado
tras las declaraciones de macrón citadas
por el diario le monde el sábado según
el artículo el líder francés criticó el
sistema político militar de argelia por
reescribir la historia basándose en su
odio a francia la nación argelina post
1962 ha vivido de la idea de que francia
es el problema desde su independencia la
élite gobernante argelina está compuesta
por militares de la guerra de liberación
de los años 50 por su parte macrón llegó
a cuestionar que la nación existiera
antes de ser colonizada por francia
tuvo que el sistema se había debilitado
debido al movimiento prodemocrático que
derrocó al presidente abdelaziz
buteflika como respuesta a argelia
retiró a su embajador de parís y acusó a
macrón de interferir en asuntos internos
ante esta situación inaceptable que han
dejado esas declaraciones irresponsables
consigo el presidente de la república
decidió llamar inmediatamente a
consultas al embajador de argelia en la
república francesa la tensión y aire
latente entre ambas naciones a raíz de
la decisión de parís de reducir en los
visados a ciudadanos de argelia
marruecos y túnez